[موسيقى]
انا تعلمت ثقافتي كلها من الصعب
لانه صف رابع بس ذكراه مشان انادي على
الاخبار اللي فيها اكون ماسك لك الجريده
هيك عين على القراءه اقراها وعين على
السيارات
خفت تضربني السيارات اذا في زبون في ناس
نقعد نرمح له لاخر الشارع
البياعين مين بده يروح للزلمه هذا اللي
بيشتري الجديد
انا احمد ابو زيد
مشهور بابو كايد من قريه السافريه انا
اقدم باع الصحف في الاردن منذ الخمسين 52
كنت اذهب على المدرسه
وانزل ابيع الصحف مسائيه واللي بتجينا من
الدول العربيه التاليه
ابيعها جراد العراقيه جريد المصريه جريده
السوريه اللبنانيه اكثر الانوار وفي جريده
الايام السوريه
وكنت ابيع جريده الاردنيه جريده اسمها
كنا نبيعها بتعريفه ناخذ فلس ونص
فلسات ونصف
كانت ثلاث صحف اربع صحف تصدر من القدس من
القدس جينا زمان
كلش ان في جريده الاردن اللي في شارع
السلط
كانت
لحتى الان حافظ السائق اللي كان يجيبها
اسمه ابو اكرم الله يرحمه اعطونا عشرين
جريده 15 جريده نلف لك عمان فيها
الصحف هي اهم شيء كانت
لانه فشل الراديو والصحف الناس انبسطت
بده يقرب
ليش لانه
في فيسبوك ولا تلفون
دير بالك مره ثانيه ان شاء الله بتنجح انا
ما بدي منك اشي الناجح خلاص يدفع في منهم
يدفع بزياده
[موسيقى]
عمر بالنسبه لي انا
في ناس هلا كل التلفون
بنام وماسك التلفون احنا الصحيفه
المجله كتاب نكره نكره
ويكون بس انا والله كنت أروح الساعه عشره
ابوي كويس الله يرحمه قال لي 100 دينار
كان بيسون
كلهم بعتبرهم اخواني
يعني في الشارع قلت لك 100 واحد بقول لك
في ناس مدمنين على الجرايد
ويقرص الصرف
المصدر الوحيد
علشان هيك يعني هلا
اخر الاخبار الدنيا
فتحنا لكم
عملوا لنا اياه وقعدنا فيها وتوكلنا على
الله
[موسيقى]